hi I'm Justine and I'm Karen and
together we'll be traveling the u.s.
only problem is we have no idea where
we're going y'all ready for this same
thing so here we are again in a van with
the 18 th ins Karen Justine thank you
for joining us you survived Alaska but
now it's time for a new city and an
entirely new experience last time your
prize was going to a show but this time
you're gonna be in a show in a show yes
we could to be in a show what kind of
show I like shows and as always are in a
race against time so you better hurry
but I'm warning you if you think you
know how the game is played you're wrong
he did that really intense thing again
he stared for a really long time
yes you were saying are you moving that
I mean you'll get your tour guides yeah
you're gonna go get our tour guides now
right well I know how this goes free
she's gonna get us some phone and then
probably blindfold us and push us out of
a van separated this is exactly what he
said last time and he gave us phones oh
oh wait don't eat those you need them to
get your phone's when you get out of the
vin you'll find a hundred steps leading
up the mountain at the top of the
mountain you'll find mr. Austin feed mr.
Austin those cookies and he'll give you
your phones so the Austin economy is
based off of baked goods but I'm warning
you mr. Austin likes to play tricks and
he'll try to pull them on you as often
as he can whoa all right get out there
and good luck you'll need it all right
well let's get gone let's go this is our
second city we've got it down we're
total pros by now wait we have to climb
I'm wearing flip-flops wow you said a
hundred steps let's do it 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
this is already weirder than anything
we've done in Alaska i am 22 23 42 43 oh
wait that doesn't count I just do 6 60
70 a 91 we're basically getting closer
and closer to the Sun with every step
with every step these cookies they're
melting I figured I'd give up and just
eat the cookie and just be like uh we're
done with this daddy 9 100 they climbed
to the top and nobody was there
completely deserted where's mr. Austin
mr. Austin then we saw the note wait
there's a note what does day hey girls
meet me at the bottom of the steps mr.
Austin p.s ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
are you serious very funny mr. Austin I
could not believe that we went all the
way up those steps for nothing and we
saw him mr. Austin you couldn't miss him
he had a little Texas out on and had a
shirt that's at Austin I liked a little
mustache it was like I couldn't tell if
he was smiling or frowning was just
there was a lot of hair on his face are
you mr. Austin nice of you ladies to
join milk cookies please oh yeah well
done I've never seen a human being eat
cookies like that before he just devours
them he was very hungry but out came the
phones Justine I have for you the
motorola v9x and karen for you the sony
ericsson w 760 a it is a slick phone
it's so tiny these phones will be your
guides throughout Austin Texas now I
have good news and bad news the good
news is you guys won't be separated for
this leg of your journey it is such a
relief the bad news why do you
handcuffed we got a handcuffed together
oh I like Justine I think she's great
and all but I don't think I want to be
handcuffed to a chair and you're gonna
have to work hard to get these handcuffs
off with you after you complete a few
challenges you'll get a clue these clues
will lead you to your final destination
in this city now I will be popping up
along the way to check up on you guys
who's gonna be following us sounds good
sounds great not so fast Justine you
have a habit of dropping your phone what
I don't drop phones was he talking about
Justine drops her phone all the time if
this phone drops five times while
completing your missions you are
disqualified what that's impossible he
laughed and then ran off like a maniac
down the street is everyone in Austin
gonna be like this
ours he going okay it's weird if this is
a sign of things to come this is going
to be quite the adventure the view out
over there he said he'd be dropping it
up he said he said he'd be dropping in
on Austin tiny I can't form sentences
today